hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so Virginia
called is saying in this essay that
moral theory has to be completely
transformed so what does that mean she's
saying there have been some things left
out and we'll look at the things that
have been left out I put them up on the
board here already we're gonna look at
each of those in a little bit more
detail but why does it have to be
completely transformed why why can't we
just sort of like do you know fix this
fix this fix this her view a lot of
people in the ethics of care see things
this way is that throughout the history
of ethics has always been male-dominated
and so when any when any particular
discourse or idea or institution is
dominated by one group what do you think
usually happens how do things work out
let's say we book you know women and men
aside and we talk about you know a
society in which there's some people of
this religion and then a minority of
this religion how do things usually get
you know set up in that society viewed
fairly or some people's ideas and views
and sentiments get cannot push to the
side what's your experience
we don't even have to use it like that
we get this thing about more mundane
things think about what you like to eat
then if you have tastes that differ from
the rest of your family and you find
yourself being overruled and you would
like to have something else and if you
want to have that something else you'd
better make it yourself because they're
not going to get it or you know it could
be this way with sports teams everybody
in your family is a such-and-such fan
you're the one holdout for this other
group and what are you going to watch on
the TV when the two games are going on
at the same time and you what most
people watch and you know if we're
talking about women and men now we're
not talking about a minority and
majority we're talking about you know
close to 50/50 in most societies and
through history you know most societies
have been male-dominated right so it
would make sense that a lot of women's
concerns or experiences would get left
out and put to the side not necessarily
because anybody said hey let's let's
stick it to the women you know we want
to make sure that they don't get any
stake in this but just because that's a
natural human tendency we all tend to
privilege our own point of view don't we
when we're connected with other people
we can learn to overcome that but that's
a natural tendency so Virginia held view
is that moral theory is left out or
devaluated women's perspectives women's
experiences and that's done some real
harm not just to women but actually also
men and two of our ability to think
about right and wrong and good and bad
so she here's a nice passage that she
she says she says moral theory is so far
developed is incapable of correcting
itself without an almost total
transformation so that's a pretty
radical thing to say Casta have an
almost total transformation it cannot
simply absorb the gender that's been
left behind even if both genders would
want to and here we get to an
interesting split between different ways
which feminism is under study so I'm not
going to go very deep into this because
there's a lot of you know other stuff
out there that you can you can access
there's more than one way to look at
feminism two of the big ways are what
you might call equality feminism and
then gender feminism and these are kind
of arbitrary names that I'm just putting
to them this isn't what everybody calls
it equality feminism is the idea that
look that the playing field is unequal
say let's say women's wages women's
wages are lower we need to make it equal
or women's opportunities are lower
we need to equalize that in some way and
then once you've actually equalized that
okay everything is okay now and we don't
have to change things any further so you
know let's take the opportunities what
would be some opportunities that women
have traditionally not in your
generation but in previous generations
then pushed out over kept up what's up
yeah the women's vote found not until
last century and in in France it did
even took even longer than it did here
in the United States so a voting that's
pretty important I don't you know if you
can't vote then you can't change things
what else what are some other things you
remember from your history classes or
sociology classes yeah
yeah they were they were fairly
restricted they mean they were allowed
to work yeah if we if we could just
understand work in general but there are
a lot of professions that they just
couldn't get into there and there's
still a lot of you know professions
today where it's still very
male-dominated it's not impossible to
get in but you know if you want to be in
a union electrician that's a pretty
male-dominated group of guys and they're
not all equally receptive to the idea of
a female electrician as a matter of fact
you might actually do better to get out
of it union context than into an open
shop that sort of thing what else
there's some other opportunities that
women didn't have as much access to or
didn't have access together yeah there
were quite a few states where a woman
couldn't actually be the there's a
special name but yeah and then that's
crippling isn't it you can't dispose of
property what about education there
there's a reason why people before your
generation and actually before mine used
to use the word couette a lot nobody
uses that these days do they what's a
co-ed Yoriko it because you're you're a
female student at least you would have
been back in the 1960s when that was
seen as not the norm I mean nowadays
there's more women in college than there
are men in college actually women tend
to do better in college
so you know she's saying you can't just
try to fix things you have to radically
transform institutions ways of looking
at things that would be what we call
gender feminism that's saying you can't
just equalize the playing field you have
to you have to change the way in which
we look at everything so she says to
continue to build morality and rational
principles opposed to the emotions and
and to include women among the arash
among the rational well they have no one
to reflect the promptings of the heart
so if we take her view of the male
approach to things the male approach to
things would be reason or rationality as
opposed to the emotions she's saying
that that you know women have been
identified with the emotions and the
emotions have been overlooked
when it comes to moral theory as a way
of deciding things this way of figuring
things out and you know that if you look
at contour utilitarianism this makes a
good sense doesn't it even Plato Plato
was you know very distrustful of the
emotions if we say well women can be
rational so we're gonna bring them into
that but we ignore the emotional side of
women just as much as we ignore the
emotional side of men we're still
ignoring the emotional side armer we're
not changing moral theory for the better
just by saying ok now women can be just
as rational as men we're still leaving
something out so she says it's also
about the public and the sort of pride
in her households fear she says to bring
women into the public and male domain
and the polis the political community
will leave no one to speak for the
household so another thing that's been
sort of ignored in moral theory is
there's a lot of focus on what goes on
in society and especially in political
society and less emphasis on what goes
on in the household and what actually
goes on in the household well that's
where childbearing and child-rearing
takes place and this is a really
important function because you know why
are kids so screwed up I've read every
generation of adults
looks at some generation of kids and
says they're very screwed up at least in
the last you know five six generations
and actually if you read the history and
literature you'll find people making
this complaint throughout all of history
just about well how do kids get screwed
up what's your experience you guys you
know are pretty well squared away
instead of young men and women you were
considered just kids you know five six
years ago right you're mixing with a lot
of other ones not everybody you know
what the path that you won some people
have dropped out some people have got
them something a lot of trouble what
determined those sort of chefs in your
experience going to bet you guys know a
lot of people who made bad choices yeah
that's a big part of it isn't that now
health is really only focusing on women
you know it's interesting since the 90s
we've learned a lot about the role of
fathers in determining outcomes not
necessarily determining isn't you know
like mechanical it's automatically going
to be this way but we've learned that if
you want to find out how children are
gonna do in school one great way of
figuring that out is look at their
relationship with the father and what
kind of person their father is but
mothering is extremely important to
probably more important in a lot of
respects than father without certain
kinds of interaction the child can't
thrive without other kinds of
interaction a child can start to form
proper attachments to other people so
you know if we just push women into the
public sphere and we say well you know a
woman can be president the woman can be
this a woman could be that you know CEO
anything but we ignore this whole
domestic sphere we're not actually
changing moral theory for the better
that's the point she's making and the
last one he has to do
the value of relationships she says to
continue to see contractual restraints
on the pursuits of self-interest by
animistic individuals what are atomistic
individuals I mean you're made of atoms
No
here we're all being available right
animistic individuals means each one of
you is an individual first outside of
the whole fabric of relationships and
you're just an individual and then
you're only in the relationships that
you're in and those only matter because
you have chosen them yourself that's not
really the case for who you are is did
any of you choose who your parents are
gonna be mad about us they're gonna be
extraordinary if you had you could
conceive of the case like a kid is going
to be adopted whether it may be 12 years
old and they can choose between this set
of parents and those centenarians but
right now along with your parents did
any other relationships come as part of
the package for you decide that are your
parents the sign of that by what they
did and you may have actually pleaded
with them please please don't have
another child but you know you get them
anyway or they came before you right
what else who else comes as a part of
the package yeah yeah I mean they're
your parents had parents too right and
maybe he has some uncles and cousins and
pretty soon you've got this whole
penumbra of all these different
relationships that you never chose and
you didn't like leave them behind if you
want to and just you know be an
animistic individual who only enters
into relationships that they want but
that's pretty rare isn't it most people
actually have quite a few relationships
and you know your parents chose a
particular place to live and that meant
that a lot of your relationships with
the people that you went to school with
and became friends with those contingent
relationships that's partly determined
by the fabric of you know networks that
you were thrown into if you had any
particular interests that you know led
you to be friends
this person because you both were the
band together or on this team together
or you know even dormant in the same
place and then found you liked the same
music or the same kind of videos you
know that's not being an animistic
individual and a lot of moral theory has
representatives as if we are these
people who are all by ourselves to begin
with and then only then do we branch out
and hook up with other people so if we
say well you know we're going to let
women come into the club and be just as
animistic and individuals as men that's
not actually going to fix things what we
want to do is figure out why the
relationships matter so much what kind
of relationships our good relationships
not just you know matters of contracts
or things like that so she's saying that
that unless we do these sorts of things
unless we bring about these kinds of
transformations moral theory is going to
be you might say held back and she yeah
she talks about this is not only being a
matter of importance for women but also
for men she says the images of the
feminine is what must be overcome if
knowledge and morality is to be achieved
you know emotion relationships this
domesticity you know where you came from
you might say a female experience is
naturally irrelevant to morality and
women as inherently deficient moral
creatures that's built into the history
of ethics and if you go back and you
look at quite a few things that some of
the people you've been reading say not
not the sections I have you read but
other sections you know you can find the
Aristotle actually saying yeah woman are
deficient they they can never be fully
rational can't even thought that now you
know did he have good grounds for
thinking that I would say no help thinks
that that was sort of you know coming
out of their culture
and inevitably push their their thinking
in a certain way that makes it not as
useful for today for conditions where we
actually do want to have you know men
and women say doing moral theory or
working in the workplace together or
maybe you know both caring about
child-rearing yeah and she says
feminists examine these images they see
that they're not the incidental or
merely idiosyncratic suppositions of a
few philosophers it's not that cot was
just you know bought that day when he
was writing it that was part of you know
his his mindset you find the same thing
in Bentham John Stuart Mill would be
kind of an interesting example because
he's actually arguing for the rights of
women but she says such views are the
nearly uniform reflection in
philosophical ethical Theory the
patriarchal attitude is pervasive
throughout human human history what our
what our patriarchal attitudes that's a
word that you guys offer in other
classes what does the patriarchy yeah
means literally men men ruling or men
running the show and we you know we just
talked about this anytime that you have
one particular group that's privileged
that's in charge they're inevitably
going to see things their way and
they're gonna make everybody else you
know fit into those categories now is
this good for women she's saying no is
this good for men she also thinks no she
says a lot of these patriarchal ideas
are exaggerations of ordinary male
experiences which exaggerations then
reinforce rather than temper other
patriarchal conceptions and institutions
they distort the actual experience and
aspirations of many men as well as women
this is something worth thinking about
and this is where I think in some ways
this may be a little dated I want you
know I want you guys to think about this
reason or rationality versus emotion do
we in fact today still associate
women more with emotion and men more
with reasoning or rationality you know
sort of a cold logical approach to
things I mean if you read stuff like you
know men are from Mars Women are from
Venus sure right but I'm not sure that
that represents your experience quite so
much I'm not even sure that represents
my experience point so much are we in a
culture where men are allowed to feel
show think about emotions let's say we
compare where we are today to what you
would think say the 1950s would be like
or even the 1970s you were watching a
70s movies
everybody's macho there are some
sensitive men and they're like the
winters over on the side here would be a
good question I met a lot of crying in
today's society or is that like wow you
go on beyond the pale you you're no
longer a man what's your experience
I mean there are some cases review cry
you're gonna get me it's fun right
there's plenty of cases where with women
crime they're gonna get made fun too
right sure if you're in you know
Ultimate Fighter doesn't matter whether
you're a guy or a girl if you're crying
you know you don't belong there but what
about ordinary life let's say you're
you're in a workplace and your colleague
and it's kind of death in the family and
they're really distracted and you need a
report from them because your work
depends on this and your boss is on your
case about this report right there's
nothing sort of like you're doing if
you're not a business person think about
this like you're doing a group project
with that but there's always somebody
who's like late with their group stuff
is why all of you don't like doing group
work
so much because the you know the risk of
that so you confront them about that and
they burst into tears now how would you
how would you view that is it okay for
them to do that I mean they're not
actually saying I won't get it done
because you know I'm feeling bad and I'm
gonna cry
is it okay for them to cry yeah does it
matter if it's a man or a woman
what will the rescue think yeah
how do you think your grandparents would
say that we'll see you I think your
grandparents are still alive so you've
got you know what you can figure out how
they would have interpreted it there in
the workplace
somebody's sad and they actually start
they break down crying and you're like
yes and even today I think that if we
finally will be crying yeah we will
accept that as okay if we come across a
man crying I will question what the hell
is wrong why are you crying
yeah yeah it might really depend on
context people question why I manage
cries and some context in both context I
mean but when a woman is crying yeah
they're not asking they're going to
question why they're crying but they're
going to
or something of that they're not going
to look at it that's critically as they
would see of manicotti I think there's
definitely more more critical judgment
when you see a man crying there's this
certain I suspect that it's somewhat
generational I think that our generation
we tend to be more strict about that
sort of stuff and I'm certainly our
parents generation way more strict about
that kind of thing but let's so let's go
on from from this so think about other
types of rationality versus emotion is
it good for four men to have to leave
that behind maybe not maybe that needs
to be integrated into all theory or you
know the experience of this domestic
sphere
you know she's putting in terms of just
childbearing and child-rearing I like to
think it was where you come from does
that matter in moral theory you know
when we looked at Allister McIntyre
earlier on a semester didn't he say that
that was really central your narrative
you know you ask the questions that you
do the unmoral theory and not abstractly
but in the situation that you're
actually living in you don't ask
necessarily what is the good for human
beings but you asked what is it good for
me
and if that has to do with where you
come from maybe where you're going back
to the sort of thing that you would like
to replicate to I think when you have
your own family and then maybe she's
onto the right track with this something
gets left out if we reduce moral theory
just to public sphere then relationships
you know is your is your self is your
way in which you carry out moral
theorizing or answering these sort of
questions should that be done as sort of
an abstract individual all by yourself
you know the categorical imperative or
Bentham's greatest happiness principle
or do your relationships really matter
you know when we looked at Ross didn't
Ross seem to offer
that kind of that kind of idea you know
duties of gratitude for example who do
you have duties of gratitude to who do
you feel duties of gratitude to Marist
of course for offer you all these great
opportunities and all that but is that
really where your heart is when it comes
to that who are you most grateful to I
think so yeah at least at this stage in
your life maybe later on and will be
something like here you know your spouse
or even your own children or the last
thing I'm going to say about it about
this before we move on to the next thing
is she is kind of vague about what what
exactly I think some care or feminist
ethics would completely entail what
would this radical transformation look
like she doesn't give you a blueprint
for that she just she's a lot more
strong in the critical side than she is
on the the constructive side and she
says you know there's dialogues that are
enabling feminist approaches to moral
theory to develop and there's no one
single view of ethics can that can be
identified as feminist ethics feminist
ethics by the way is not necessarily the
same thing as ethics of care you could
perhaps recognize some of the truths in
the ethics of care without tying in with
some sort of you know big grand feminist
program so that's something we're
thinking about